so today we have James hoary of open
core whorie whorie whorie whorie i'll be
talking about docker and ferry a way to
sort of interact with talker from Python
so let's welcome James well thank you
for being here um so as a caveat again
you know I was mentioning to that this
is not necessarily a programming talk
but about all the machinery and
infrastructure that you often need to do
really interesting visualizations or
data programming so it's more about the
systems that go along with that and some
of the new technologies have been coming
out in the open source community to
really try to automate and help
developers like yourself and data
scientists cope with this but really
it's about a story and I'd like to tell
this as a story about a developer who is
getting into Python and data
visualizations and want to really share
her results with the rest of the world
and with other developers and maybe is
having a harder time than she really
should and talking about some of those
solutions and why that's the case and
our story basically comes in three parts
that one is the story about where she's
going to get started writing a Boca
application because she's a new Python
programmer and this seems like a great
way to do it and it's going to be
followed by her discovery of a cool tool
called docker and we're going to go over
why that's such a neat tool and finally
we're going to talk about orchestration
of various docker containers and that
may may not may not make sense a lot of
you until you go through some of these
examples and again this is pretty high
level but certainly after the
presentation if you have questions about
the implementation or how this actually
works you know just feel free to ping me
and before I continue I would like to
point out that all the technical
material for this presentation including
the examples are on the following github
project page that also has links to the
various dependencies to get up and
started you probably don't want to
download docker and the vagrant my
vagrant box right now it's kind of large
as a couple piggeh bites I'm sure of
Facebook's why
this infrastructure is pretty good but
we want to be in kind of good neighbors
or heads we don't want to flood their
network so our story starts here one day
our developer is approached by her team
lead and are keenly just asks they work
at a consulting company says hey we have
this new client and they're really
interested in data visualization and we
want you to do something around
geospatial data being a relatively new
Python programmer she doesn't googling
and finds this project the Boca project
and it looks really really nice in fact
that you know has a lot of different
type of graph types and geospatial types
she's originally Java programmer so this
looks super exciting for her so on she
decides okay this is the route that I'm
going to go right totally makes sense
but before she gets too far she's
beginning to think okay if I'm going to
create a little demo application using
Boca only some data so what data should
I use well how about the u.s. census
data why not it's you know it's widely
available it's a it's free it's pretty
rich has a lot of geospatial information
in it maybe you can do something like
create a state-by-state map at a county
level of median and per capita income
across the United States and then she
can add different sort of graph types if
you click on something I would be an
example of an application she could
write using Boca and the US Census well
how do you access the US Census well
luckily for her the US Census provides a
nice restful api to let you download
this data you know it's just a plain
rest-based API they don't provide any
external clients but that's not a
problem it looks pretty straightforward
the structure you just give it a code
that defines what data you want out of
this system and some sort of geospatial
contacts what county and what state for
example you know unfortunately it's not
necessarily obvious to her exactly how
to get these codes and what that means
but they do provide an extensive
documentation so she clicks through then
she says oh yeah you know what turns out
for total median income across all
population groups that's DP 0 3
0062 e that's pretty obvious right you
know it's not necessarily intuitive but
it's pretty straightforward she doesn't
really feel like typing all of that in
over and over and over and over again
and she thinks this is a good
opportunity to use Python and to get
started downloading this information so
she just writes a simple Python function
using requests and you know the simple
JSON parsing on that data really the
only tricky part of course since this is
the US government is that you don't give
it a state name or county name or
anything like that you have to provide
them with codes numeric codes so does
anybody know what I'm code the state of
Tennessee is probably not you know I
think it's 25 or something like that so
she has to code that up but it's not too
big of a deal and after she does that
she gets this really nice on download of
the data broken down so this is mean
median and per capita income broken down
by counties and state nice and you know
nicely formatted and this you know only
took her an hour so you know even though
she's a new Python programmer so great
and she's from Texas so that's why she
downloaded the data on Texas and in
Texas she was just scanning this and she
sees a look at that boarding County over
there has a pretty good mean median and
per capital income I wonder where that
is so just for fun should look that up
it turns out it's basically out in the
middle of nowhere there are like 600
people that live in this county but
apparently they make a pretty good
income especially compared to the people
in Brooks County or not doing as well
okay fine so this is good this is good
so she has a program to download some
data to format that data she's off to a
pretty good start with her demo and now
it's time to go ahead and install Boca
okay keep in mind that she's a new
Python programmer she hasn't gone
through this process before but she's
smart you know in chi Google's and
everybody talks about hey go ahead and
use pit sweet okay so she types in pip
install Boca and it starts printing a
bunch of stuff to the screen she's like
oh that
fantastic i'll let it do its thing on
gonna grab some coffee and I'll come
back and after a few minutes she comes
back and she sees this funny error
something about Python H and compiling
and she's like okay I guess that's not
good why I have to worry about header
files and Python I don't really
understand this but you know at least it
gives me a nice suggestion try to
install Python dev not in pip of course
just install it somehow using your
favorite package manager which for her
she's using a boon to so she says okay
apt-cache search Python dev hi look I
found it go ahead and install that and
rerun pip install and everything's going
fine again lots of stuff printing out to
the screen it's chugging along she's
like okay we're going to get this
working and then she gets this really
messed up error from GCC of all places
something about CC 1 plus and no such
vile and she's like what the crap is
this I just want to get some plot and
she has no idea what this means so she
turns to Google right she copies is and
has something about i installing g plus
plus okay so she nice and slow g plus
plus and she's kind of getting
frustrated she's like I'm using Python
geez why I've installed like all these
header files and algae plus plus but she
goes ahead install that reruns pip
install and bam she has Boca it
installed success right she can move
forward so she writes a super simple
Python script right to just import the
Boca library that's all it does those
two lines she got this from the example
web page right it's not you know just
import those libraries and she hits go
she hits run Python run and now she gets
another error it's like oh the sample
data directory doesn't exist just run
this command first run it where and what
why do I need to run this but she's like
okay this is clearly ipython errors i'm
going to go into the python Repole you
know import this and go ahead and say
Boko sample data
download and in fact it just downloaded
some data packages for her right and
finally she can do that import statement
again and get a boca application written
okay this is a pretty simple example but
even here it's been a pretty frustrating
process for is taking a long time but
okay she's pretty intrepid and she moves
forward and let's fast forward and she
eventually gets a nice plot by example
written that can take the doubt data
downloaded from the US census formats it
correctly uses boca to create this nice
geospatial map of the median income
across counties she's really tired of
staring at texas so she does Kentucky
just for fun and this is what she gets
okay great now she has some sort of demo
just for fun that red area means highest
per capita income and that's Louisville
that's largest city in Kentucky the
orange and yellow spots or other major
metropolitan areas it's not so happy to
live here though you know it's not that
densely populated kind of poor so yeah
that's Louisville right there and you
know this this is good right so she has
this demo working and everything's going
really well and people kind of like her
demo and she gets this email from her
team Lee that asked her to create this
demo and the team he says hey this looks
fantastic let's give this demo to our
client now just rat these throw these
HTML pages in a flask app so we can
serve it up but by the way we're trying
to save money so you can't go but I'll
go you just transfer your application to
my laptop and i'll give the demo I mean
what could what could go wrong it's a
super simple app I only took you like
four or five hours from scratch to do
this right and she's thinking yeah right
what could go wrong and she begins
thinking okay I need to recreate this
environment right but at least i went
through these steps i'll just look
through my bash history and i'll just
stick that into my bash ball and it's
going to look kind of like this okay and
of course i have to type these in the
right right order and so forth and you
know it's it's kind of short you know it
didn't
this short when she was running it but
you know it's not that complex and she
emails him dispatch ball or uploads it
to their git repo or whatever and he's
like okay great and he runs it and he's
like the conversation that ensues goes
something like this oh yeah your scrip
didn't work um yeah I don't know why
something funny printed to the screen I
have no idea why uh yeah I type that oh
ok I'll do it as you don't know it still
didn't work it's like wait what what am
i running I'm running redhat you know
that's the official you know image that
we're supposed to run why are you
running a boon to look why don't you
just walk over to my office and just fix
this because I have to leave like in 30
minutes she's like oh crap so but she
know she walks over and she fixes it and
she goes through the whole process again
on his machine you know instead of a
cute its young and the packages are
called a little bit different and few
more errors but after an hour or so you
know it's running sweet and so the team
league gives that demo it was a huge
success and she gets to keep working on
this project and develop it into a full
application and he says as part of that
if you can make sure that the other
developers on our team and with our
clients can also download the app once
in a while and run it because we may
want to give additional demos right that
would be great and she's thinking yeah
this is great so now I'm might have to
go through this process again sharing
the same application as I develop it you
know should be easy but not as easy as
you know she would like so and she's
thinking about that she's
procrastinating and she's reading stuff
on hacker news and she sees this thing
about docker this project called docker
she doesn't really know what it's about
but everybody's talking about it she
visits you know has a cute icon you know
who could not like that icon and she
goes to the github page and slide holy
crap this thing has over 10,000 github
stars and it's only you know six nine
months old that this thing must be
awesome
know what it is but it must be awesome
so she digs a little deeper and she
learns that in fact docker is addressing
the exact same problem that she has
right now it's a way to fully
encapsulate the runtime environment in a
set of lightweight quote containers and
basically the end result of this is that
it makes it easy and safe to reproduce
that runtime environment or and to ship
her entire application as a binary image
of some sort and it's super easy to get
started and she thinks okay this is what
I'm going to use so how do I get started
while she goes through the various
tutorials and she runs the equivalent of
hello world i'm not going to show you
this it's pretty straightforward can go
to doc or I oh and look at that but
really the heart of the matter comes
down to what they call the dockerfile
now for those have used vagrant it's
kind of like you're vagrant file except
if you look at this what you would
notice is that it's a lot simpler
basically think of the docker file as
her bash script in a slightly more
controlled same manner so you take the
bash grip and append various commands
like run and add that have very obvious
meanings run means run this in the
container add means add this to the
container and the statements are run
from top to bottom so let's look at this
first she has to choose a base image
this is the image that her container
starts with from a clean install it's as
if you just took this base image had it
on your own machine and nothing else
installed that's the base image she
likes a boon to she's going to go with
1204 since that's what she's using and
that name statement up there that's a
very specific thing dr. is going to
ignore that but it's kind of nice i
think to name your containers then she's
going to install everything the
dependencies at this point she knows
that she has appt get she knows exactly
what's on this environment and she can
just run these commands pretty
straightforward nothing too complex
she's kind of cleaned up her scripts
since this time so she just adds a bunch
of these files into her container and
then finally she needs a
default command this means that when you
start the container I want the following
script or whatever command in there to
be run she just wrote this shell script
to start her web server to start serving
out her HTML pages then what she's going
to do is build this container using the
docker build command and then you know
the whole build process most of that
time is probably going to go towards
just installing this you know the active
part if it's going to compile a bunch of
stuff that will take some time but it's
really not that bad and once that image
is built she can then push that image on
to dr. iOS publix index server and what
that means is she can push that image
onto a server where other people can
then download that image it's kind of
like if you again if you use vagrant
it's kind of like creating a vagrant box
and pushing it out to a public vagrant
server except it's free you know the
doctor people kindly has given us the
ability to upload open source images for
free which is awesome so thanks dr. team
now she's done this so this is pretty
awesome so what's the next step now the
whole point of this exercise was for her
colleagues and her team we'd to be able
to pull her application or to demo her
application so all they have to do is
type in those two commands assuming they
have dr. installed on their linux box
this is becoming easier and easier Red
Hat officially supports soccer now and
their long term server releasing with a
boon to it's becoming pretty
straightforward and once they have dr
installed all they have to do say dr.
Poole my image name that goes through a
download process and then they can just
run that container the only weird part
is that dash PFLAG that's just a port
forwarding mapping that's all it is but
basically they're just saying run that
container and this is just a visual
illustration to show you that that
container is running on top of your host
operating system okay now tell you about
the consequences of then just
a while but the nice thing is that as
soon as your colleague go through those
commands and runs I command all they
have to do is open up their browser go
to port 8000 or whatever other port you
map and they're going to see the exact
same thing that she saw when she
uploaded that image and in fact
everybody will it will be exactly
reproduced in in their environment which
is pretty awesome and in fact you can do
something crazy like run this image
multiple times and each time you run
that image that image believes that
container believes it owns that complete
environment it's completely isolated so
in technical parlance what's going on is
stalker is using technologies like Linux
containers aufs and process remapping so
that it looks like each time you run it
it's almost as if it gets his own
virtual environment or virtual machine
it's very similar you know qualitatively
to doing that except each time someone
hits that run command it takes about one
second to actually go ahead and start
that so compared to a more traditional
method using virtual machines yes you
can end up in the same state but it's
just going to be a lot slower and a lot
heavier and because the Linux kernel is
really just doing some clever process
and namespace isolation the overhead
from using a docker container is super
low in fact I would pretty much
challenge anyone to actually notice the
amount of CPU and memory overhead
associated with docker containers
basically it's like running a native
process so you get all the pros of
running an isolated environment like
using virtual machines with almost none
of the cons there are some caveats
though this is based on linux it doesn't
run natively on OS 10 or windows and so
you know it's a little bit more
restrictive but if you are in that
environment it's really really nice and
just FYI if you do have dr running and
you don't mind downloading some stuff
you can just type in these commands
right now until your terminal and you
should get this demo up and running
because this is real time oh right you
can do that it's going to be about a few
hundred megabytes or so
so okay great so she has a demo she can
share her demo with her colleagues in a
reproducible way it's kind of looking
professional and her team Lee comes up
to her and says you know what this is
really awesome why don't we take this
demo and develop it and make it into an
application that we can sell because you
know I think our consulting company
should really be a software company
because that's how you scale and make
lots of money you already have a demo so
what's the big deal right I mean just
kind of build off of this and she's
thinking you know that okay fine this
sounds like an awesome suggestion so
where do we get started first we need
more data you know this amount of data
is not interesting more US census data
they have you know tens of gigabytes of
data maybe we can get daily weather data
across zip codes and counties from
Weather Underground maybe we can get
geotagged tweets we can take all this
data sell it as a business marketing
platform and businesses will pay us to
access this clean data is going to
change the world it's going to be
awesome and I'm going to become super
rich and dr. is going to help me do this
but wait before we get there she's
thinking okay with all this data we
probably need a database at this point
storing them in CSV files yeah probably
not going to cut it for our startup so
what database well it's going to be a
highly scalable you know database
because you know my startup her startup
is going to be super successful we're
going to have a million users tomorrow's
that we need to think about scale so why
not use Cassandra hey Cassandra was
developed here at Facebook so we know
it's scalable thanks Facebook you're
awesome you know you give us a bunch of
awesome tools and the way Cassandra
works is that you have all of these
machines numbered one through seven and
they're logically ordered in a token
ring basically and the idea is that as
you send a bunch of rights and perform a
bunch of reeds we're going to select
some subset of those machines to execute
those commands and you can keep adding
machines is super simple you can even
take away machines so super fault
tolerant and Cassandra just seems like a
very nice
database to use but it seems a little
complex I mean just look at this diagram
it she kind of wishes there were only
like three boxes instead of ten boxes
but is it complex well it turns out that
it's not so bad once upon a time it is
true that Cassandra and other scalable
databases like HBase use terminology
that no one else understood they use
weird words like super column and column
family and rows that actually weren't
rose and you know that's kind of
completed issues but more recently on
the people on the in the Cassandra
community and companies like datastax
have come up with a language called CTL
which is basically like SQL except for
Cassandra and in order to start modeling
your data you create something like this
you know this looks pretty familiar to
those that use relational databases you
create a table you specify their types
this parts a little weird this is a
compound key but not too big with you
it's not too much of a job so she thinks
okay this is great i'm going to use
Cassandra so how do we get started well
she has a couple different options she
can shove all of these she can shove all
of these dependencies in her single
docker file including the Cassandra
dependency she can install it in her
docker file and run that and build that
you know that's the pros to that are
that it's pretty simple or she can try
to begin orchestrating that so let's
look at these options so yeah she's
basically dealing with simple versus
flexible and at the end of the day she
begins thinking well you know what I
don't really want to build and maintain
a dozen docker files especially the
Cassandra docker file I'm not a
Cassandra expert I don't really want to
be a Cassandra expert maybe there's a
better way to do this and it turns out
that of course lots of people have
written docker images that you can find
on the docker index that's great she
should reuse those but that means now
she has to begin thinking about how to
orchestrate these various docker
services which is kind of a pain but she
thinks not a problem I'll just write a
shell script that pulls the images
then starts this database then this
database and make sure the IP address of
this goes into that and should let wait
wait we've been down this road before
bash cribs suck I am NOT doing this
again docker help me fix this problem i
am not going down this route again it's
not as bad this time emitting li but
it's still not an optimal situation so
she begins thinkin hey is there a better
way to do this luckily for her there is
a better way to do this ferry is one
approach and basically what Barry lets
her do is to specify the entire runtime
environment both up front end and back
end in a single yamel file okay and she
can say i want a hadoop cluster or
cassandra cluster and I want these
docker containers attached to them
automatically okay that's all it all it
does and so the way I kind of think of
Faerie and other orchestration tools is
is almost like pip okay we're in pip you
get to specify all the various things it
depends on and you expect the system to
handle it for you I'm doing the same
thing except for lots of services in
your runtime environment so this is a
very home page definitely check it out
you know there are some nice
installation procedures and if you're
running OS 10 there's actually a fairy
vagrant box that you can just in it and
download it's like a three gigabyte box
so be warned so what does her
application look like at this point
basically there are just two elements
the top one is our yamo file this is a
super simple example where she says I
want a Cassandra cluster I just want to
use this over one instance you can
actually change that and specify a
hundred instances is not a big deal the
reason why you would want to do that on
your laptop create a hundred virtual 100
node virtual cluster it's like Cassandra
and other tools like a do lets her
control how data is distributed across
these machines and it's not trivial to
test this in a non production
environment but very let's err do that
because these are all virtual nodes even
though they're running in the
distributed manner and they're all
lightweight she also wants a client
she's just going to call it the PI data
Cassandra
I to expose port 8000 she also needs to
rejigged her docker file that she
originally had and it's not too
different the only differences are one
that she needs to base it from the ferry
Cassandra client that makes sure that
she has the right drivers installed and
there are some locations of some of
these scripts that need to be moved so
that they're started in the right order
with respect to Cassandra it's really
not too different from her original
docker file and then that's it so now
assuming she has very installed and
she's written these EML files in this
new doctor fall she just needs to point
ferry to her new yamo file say start and
is going to go ahead and automatically
configure and configuring the Cassandra
cluster and make sure that client can
connect to that cluster all
automatically so all the configuration
happens for her and this process for
Cassandra even when we're talking dozens
of virtual nodes usually takes about 10
seconds something like a dupe is
actually a little bit more complicated
may take 20 or 30 seconds but that's it
and the best part is just like docker
she can start multiple virtual clusters
and ferries going to manage that for her
so here is just one but you know usually
my development I'll usually have a dozen
clusters or so running on my laptop she
can also adjust for fun SSH into one of
these connectors these connectors are
just regular docker containers but she
can ssh into it and if she does a PS so
look her web servers actually running
and being exposed on port 8000 so at the
end of the day it doesn't look too
different from her original docker demo
he still sells the same web application
he still access it the same way except
this time is actually being backed up by
a Cassandra cluster which is pretty nice
so she so what she begins wondering
what's actually going on when you do
start for Cassandra is actually pretty
simple in this example we're starting to
Cassandra nodes basically those are the
yellow boxes ferry is going to stand out
these containers build them
automatically these are just docker
containers automatically generate the
configuration falls necessary
for those two notes to talk to each
other and then also automatically
configure the client to be able to talk
to those connectors and georgina
afterwards she can look at the
environment environment variables and
barriers kind enough to point her to the
right IP addresses so that you can begin
interacting with those with that
Cassandra cluster so what if she wanted
to do something more example or complex
so in this example what she's going to
do is start a cluster file system a
cluster f s parallel file system this is
basically like NFS except where the data
is distributed over multiple machines it
was kind of funny i think in one of
yesterday's talks face it turns out that
facebook users cluster which is pretty
awesome and she's also wants to
instantiate a compute part of hadoop
it's called yarn basically to operate
over that data in cluster file system
well it turns out that you can just
write a yellow file for this let's just
call it yarn and you can just start it
and even though what Barry has to do to
get this running is more complex there
are more containers the configuration
management is a bit more complex and
there's a little bit slower to get
started from her perspective it looks
exactly the same you start it you can
ssh into the connectors and you can
download and configure it however you
want and afterwards you can just shut it
down and Cassandra & M ferry is going to
automatically clean up all the resources
you know exactly as you would expect now
at this stage let's take a step back and
think about what she's accomplished
right so he has this awesome demo it's
hitting Cassandra it's looking pretty
good and she begins thinking well what
do I need to do at this stage well
wouldn't it be nice if she could get
some feedback from the wider development
community on github or wherever on her
progress right and maybe there are some
other applications that other people
would like to share as well but there's
not an obvious way to do this for these
fairy applications but luckily for her
this is a feature that's going to come
out relatively soon if you buy me beer
and might come out sooner
but basically I'm going to let her
upload her containers and her
configuration files to open core server
and that way you can do something like
share this image and then pull an entire
application stack locally on your
machine so after she pushes her demo
online you can then just pull that and
you'll also get the exact same Cassandra
cluster with all the same data and so
forth running which is pretty nice for
and it gives a lot of valuable feedback
but course at the end of the day she
wants to make some money which really
mean she needs to take this demo in her
application and deployed at scale right
because there's one thing to run it on
your laptop or development you have to
get alive and running so wouldn't it be
great if she could just do this all
within ferry she really doesn't want to
go out and purchase this service from
that company and this service from that
company and you know do this from AWS
and so forth well it turns out that she
can do this if she wanted to sign up for
a to be one of my beta users she could
type the following command if she has
her application written all she has to
do is say deploy this she just needs to
provide ferry with her AWS credentials
and every single one of her containers
is going to be automatically translated
into a full-blown virtual machine the
same configuration everything that she
installed in her web client whether she
compiled something or did an appt get
download whatever is going to be
automatically in her easy to environment
and then afterwards she can continue
managing the application using ferry so
she can still stop it restart it
snapshot it and so forth except it's
actually running at scale so that's
pretty neat and so this concludes our
story for now and you know I kind of
like to think of this as the story that
of a developer who really was just
getting into Python and development and
somehow accidentally ended up being the
CTO of an awesome start up around you
know docker and Python but along the way
she's learned some valuable lessons that
I think is speaks true for many of us
that one even running and installing
simple applications in this case a Boca
application can be complex and certainly
maintaining that runtime environment is
just not fun to dr. solves largely a lot
of these problems if you're running in a
single environment okay if you if you're
willing to deal with single containers
it largely salsas problems so if you're
not using docker now download docker
install it and begin using it you will
thank me later it is awesome but at the
same time dr. doesn't solve all these
problems because ultimately like
anything you still have to deal with
orchestration across runtime services
now and fortunately for her there are
many open-source tools that are being
you know brought up right now to help
solve this problem ferry is not the only
one very focuses on Big Data stacks and
Big Data orchestration but there are
many other tools so luckily for her she
can just choose which one makes sense
for her so thank you for paying
attention I'm James Horry that's my
email feel free to email me visit the
Pharaoh Concordia website go ahead and
install ferry there's a simple vagrant
box it's fun to use and if you have any
questions you can email me or send me a
tweet thanks
hello yeah it was a great dog Thank You
up of what happens to the state of the
container when you make some changes
after you ssh into it like can you save
it well yeah so um there's a doctor
answer and there's a very answer and
they're mostly the same if you're just
using a plain docker container one you
can't just ssh into it you have to start
the ssh server and all that stuff but if
you could if you stop the container and
restart it your state is basically saved
and that's true in fairy as well if you
want to persist those changes across
reboots right or after an upload both
docker and ferry come with specific
commands to snapshot that data or can
create a new container based off of that
so my suggestion is you know especially
dealing with docker is once you're in
that container if you're making lots of
changes you want to say that go ahead
and save that as a new container and
ferry go ahead and snap snap shot that
stack over here so at the risk of being
that guy can I ask about cross-platform
eNOS in the sense that you look around
and everyone's using a mac and then we
have to go into our virtual machine and
then yeah I'm worried about the sort of
turducken aspect of of all this yeah is
there is there any sort of hope for
being able to have these kind of
universal dock or intervals of Faerie
files yeah so that's actually a really
really great question you know this is a
really contentious issue on the in the
docker community right now doctor is
only natively supported on the linux
kernel plus some bsd kernels no one
turns out no one cares about bsd Turtles
but it's fine on so in theory it could
be supported on OS 10 right assuming
that Apple continues to patch there
colonel and make those
capabilities available when that happens
I don't really know I don't believe it's
really on the docker roadmap for any
time soon which really means
unfortunately that fair reasons it
relies on docker underneath won't run
natively in those environments having
said that the recommended way of going
about running this on OS 10 or windows
is basically use vagrant or create a
virtual machine image one thing that I'm
playing around with with fairy is
creating an online hosted service so
chances are i'm just going to create a
fairy box that's just constantly running
so if you want it to just play around
with fairy and play around with docker
you know just shoot me an email and i'll
keep give you an account you can ssh
into that and begin playing around with
that but that's kind of a cop-out answer
unfortunately i don't know but that's
definitely something that I hope is
addressing near future docker runs on
mac sort of with the you know butta
daughter yeah the virtual machine server
sort of thing that they have does very
work with that on like kind of natively
on a Mac using that kind of indirection
layer yeah so the answer is no and the
reason why is that the official way of
running docker on OS 10 is to use an
image called butta docker it's just a
minimal Linux image that runs on a
virtual machine you know it's kind of
like a vagrant box but the last time I
checked is a 32-bit image and docker
requires this 64-bit linux image as soon
as butta docker becomes negatively
64-bit then the answer will be yes if
you already have dr installed by the way
the easiest way to use fairy is to run
fairy inside of docker so it's way too
many nests but you can do that which is
crazy so you can spin up a Linux VM
install docker run ferry in docker to
spin up other docker containers in the
or container it actually kind of works
which is amazing but yeah I was gonna
say we should probably call it soon
maybe one more quick question um do you
envisage that ferry might become
somewhat of a supervisor for those
orchestrations so that you know the
absence of upstart inside of the doctor
container kind of gets solved yeah you
know I think I think that's a really
tall order to solve the orchestration
problem completely you know what I've
seen is that different orchestration
methods are targeting difference for the
communities so the web community has
their own particular needs around queues
and things like that whereas the Big
Data community has slightly different
needs whether that kind of convergys
into a single orchestration system for
containers like docker yeah I think so
but it might be quite some time before
we see that but in the meantime I think
it makes more sense to focus on the
needs of very specific communities okay
all right thanks all right I was great
let's go change the other hand
go back a few minutes
you